as coronavirus restrictions around the
world
closed many holiday destinations premier
league footballers headed to mykonos
for the clear waters clear blue skies
and all day beach parties but for harry
maguire
it was down these narrow whitewashed
back streets that it all went wrong
[Music]
this video shows him enjoying himself on
thursday night
peter was the man behind the lens
everybody wants a picture with harry and
he don't say no i don't own pictures do
you think it will be forgotten about
here of course of course footballers
will still be welcome in mykonos
why not why not it's
very usually to fight or to drink a lot
in the high-end shops and flashy bars
they're keen to protect the privacy of
vip
guests but stories have spread quickly
about how the manchester united
captain ended up in a police cell and
then about 12 o'clock
from here barman apostles often sees
international football stars passing by
they weren't friendly you know
so the next day that i learned about the
fact
i didn't believe this it was outside
this bar
now closed the fight broke out sky news
understands that maguire's defense will
claim
that two albanian men were harassing his
sister daisy
and stabbed her with a sharp object
mykonos police alleged mcguire and two
others then assaulted officers
and attempted to bribe them harry harry
are you pleased with how that went
after his first hearing maguire didn't
respond to my questions
he won't appear in court for his second
hearing but experts say he faces charges
of misdemeanors
rather than the more serious felonies
the highest sentence can be up to
five years plus a heavy fight
most of these crimes
have big and heavy fines it's unlikely
that harry maguire will end up in prison
for this
for sure no what happens inside the main
courthouse in cirrus will not only
affect harry maguire
it could have a huge bearing on the
england team
because on the very same day the manager
gareth southgate is set to pick his
squad
for the upcoming nations league fixtures
maguire would usually be an almost
guaranteed selection but this time it's
not straightforward
whether the verdict is guilty or not
maguire will be desperate to leave the
memory of his summer holiday in greece
behind
martha kellner sky news syros